speaking of corruption in our government
we've got this new report here right
here from the daily wire
about how the CIA may have had a
relationship with the man who killed
Kennedy
we're still debating the man who killed
Kennedy all these years later and what's
what's so interesting about it
is that the sides have sort of flipped
in people's theories
Lee Harvey Oswald he's the man who
killed Kennedy new report says
that Oswald was tied to the CIA before
the JFK assassination right before the
JFK assassination why is this coming out
now Jefferson Morley
is a journalist and an author and he
said this during a press conference in
D.C on Tuesday this is less than two
weeks before the December 15th deadline
to release still classified records
related to the JFK assassination so even
now 60 70 years later uh no I guess
about six years later we've got
uh
information that is still classified
about the Kennedy assassination
and Morley who's this journalist says
quote what the CIA is hiding is what
they've always hidden which is their
sources and methods as they relate to
Lee Harvey Oswald we're talking about
Smoking Gun proof of a CIA operation
involving Lee Harvey Oswald asserting
that this took place in the summer of
1963 not long before the Kennedy
assassination and Oswald later denied
Killing Kennedy he said that he was just
a patsy
and then of course we never had a trial
because Lee Harvey Oswald was shot dead
on national TV at the Dallas Police
Headquarters by Jack Ruby
now the story has always been that Lee
Harvey Oswald acted alone only one
gunman government didn't know anything
government didn't do anything and spe
conspiracy theories have always swirled
around I don't use that term derisively
as we know these days the difference
between a conspiracy theory and the
truth is about three to six months but I
just mentioned it because they are
theories about potential conspiracies
involving the Communists involving the
mob involving the government involving
all sorts of people
involving LBJ but there are all sorts of
theories about this
the most interesting part of the story
to me
is that
but the whole time I was growing up
the people who peddled
the conspiracy theories about the
Kennedy assassination that is the people
who did not believe the official
government story
we're on the left it was always the
leftist it was always Oliver Stone it
was always these these far left Wingers
who said no it was the CIA you know it
was this it was that
the people on the right
generally accepted the government's
story
and said no look the guy was a communist
and a communist went out and killed
Kennedy and that's that a simple simple
case
that has started to change
today the roles have basically flipped
today it is even beyond the Kennedy
assassination it is the left
that defends the CIA it is the left that
defends the FBI it is the left that
defends the Deep State and the
government it is the right that is very
skeptical of all of those organizations
it is the right it is skeptical of all
of those institutions
what does this represent well it just
represents in the perception the popular
perception
20 30 years ago
there was this perception that
the Republicans were kind of the
establishment
I'm not saying that was true I'm just
saying that was the perception today it
is firmly established in the minds of
everybody the libs control all those
institutions the libs control the
government and the Deep State and all
the rest of it and the libs lie through
those institutions constantly
and the conservatives aren't realizing
this so conservatives saw this right up
close during covid
the conservatives saw this right up
close during the FBI scam the Russia
hoax the conservatives saw this right up
close during the New FBI scam put
pressuring big Tech to censor the 100
Biden laptop story The conservatives saw
this up close with the FBI Scandal when
Obama's IRS went after conservative
groups
we've just seen this so much for years
and so when when people raise questions
about the Kennedy assassination
especially on the right
that's not the conservative's fault
that's not the fault of of tin foil hat
fueled crazy conspiracy theories
it's the fault of the deep State it's
the fault of those institutions its
fault of the left which has wielded them
in a very corrupt way speaking of John
Kennedy a different John Kennedy Senator
John Kennedy has a Manifesto for
conservatives a clip that just went
viral a few days ago
they hate George Washington
they hate Thomas Jefferson
they hate Dr Zeus and they hate Mr
Potato Head
the these woke
high IQ stupid people they walk around
they walk around with Ziploc bags of
kale
that they can eat to give them energy
now if you want to eat kale that's up to
you
I don't eat kale you know why
because kale tastes to me like I'd
rather be fat
and these high iqp stupid people the
walkers in charge of Washington DC the
berserk wind of the Democratic Party
they hyperventilate on their yoga mats
if if you use the wrong pronoun they're
all over Washington DC
here here
I I Adore this bit I had I absolutely
adore this stump speech from John
Kennedy
uh it's not the most specific one well
it is specific in the details of the
jokes he's making
but I just love this idea
of going after the high IQ stupid people
in this really clunky comedic way
because
John Kennedy is an extremely intelligent
and extremely educated man
this guy has has degrees from Vanderbilt
UVA and modeling College Oxford in the
United Kingdom this guy is very very
educated
and it comes out and he talks like
Foghorn Leghorn and really the the
comparison that I see here
is with
Norm Macdonald Norm Macdonald also
brilliant brilliant guy not particularly
educated self-educated but really an
extraordinarily intelligent guy
who would play kind of a dummy and say
oh yeah man no no not really a smart guy
you know or anything like that Matt died
and then he would just hit you with
something that was so
sharp and incisive and would destroy the
pretensions of our supposedly genius
Bettors who run the world
the the thing that conservatives have to
do well one what it embodies is a kind
of humility where we don't need to
always seem like the fanciest people in
the world and we're all we believe in
all the really fashionable theories and
we oh yes we're taken very seriously all
the cocktail parties and all these nice
fancy apartments in New York and now and
we gotta forget about that there's a
kind of humility that says no I'd rather
be with truck drivers than with the Dr
fauces of the world the truck drivers
actually understand the world better
okay and I know that's not how it's
presented in the popular culture but it
is the case fauci wrong about everything
truckers write about a lot of things
maybe not everything but a lot of things
okay that's just the way that it works
Roger scrutin said that the job of a
conservative intellectual is to
articulate
things that Ordinary People understand
intuitively
yeah it's kind of
enough because normal people kind of get
it and it's just the self-styled
intellectual Elite of our ruling class
that don't understand these sorts of
things what conservatives have to do
is
awaken people from the intellectual
trance of our idiotic Elite because
there are a lot of people especially
young people especially people in
uh college and high school and where all
of the the elite leftists are really
preying on them and trying to warp their
minds who who they want to be the smart
people they say well all the people in
the fancy lab coats all the people with
the fancy neckties they're all on the
left and we need to awaken people to
that and point out that these are high
IQ stupid people
I'm sure that a lot of our Elite have
relatively High IQs but they're stupid
they say things that are not true they
say things like men can become women
they say things like babies or people
they say things like the world is going
to end in five years because of the sun
monster they say all sorts of stupid
things and I I think the John Kennedy
approach is a great way to do it what
I'm saying y'all hear about this I don't
want to eat kale because kale when I
taste it it makes me want to be fat
that's it's a great bit the rest of the
show continues now you do not want to
miss it if you're not a member click the
link in the description and join us
[Music]
[Music]